julianne i wanted to start with you here
because it's a big enough challenge
playing an icon like gloria steinem
here you're sharing that role with three
other people so
i guess what were some of the either
challenges or maybe advantages of
sharing the role
oh i think there were great advantages
to having to having people
having multiple people play you know
represent gloria steinem there wasn't
the responsibility then to be the kind
of the ultimate gloria to be the exact
gloria
i think julie understood that we were
communicating a life
um we weren't sort of like i'm trying to
try to copy it
you know specifically so i so i love the
fact that we were
all these different stages of her and
and so
so also not just her but also kind of
what what the movement was
what what glorious life meant to the
women's movement and how it encapsulated
that
um but then the best part of it was
really getting to like you know
to to read her books and to to listen to
recordings of her voice and to watch her
on her tv appearances to spend some time
in her in her presence which was a
magnificent learning experience
i still can't believe i spoke to her for
a couple minutes a little while ago
still blowing my mind
lorraine i wanted to get your take on
multiple actors playing
gloria in this too because you're one of
the few who actually gets to act
opposite too glorious so was there
anything that really struck you
about that process um
two very different actresses approaching
it in in
i think different ways but at the end of
the day
uh when i stood opposite them i was
talking to
gloria um and uh you know that's the
caliber of actors that julie
is able to attract and you know everyone
julie picks up the phone and calls and
you say yes
and then you figure out what it is
you've just said yes to so
um no it's a magnificent cast and
those the multiple the the group scenes
especially
uh the newspaper scenes and and and the
miss magazine scenes
gosh those were really fun when we were
all in the sandbox together
uh wonderful actresses playing iconic
characters
i did want to ask you about the uh the
scenes
in the office because you're both such
experienced and accomplished actors and
just
even beyond your performance when you're
when you're on set what do you both like
to do
to kind of create the best possible tone
especially when you're sharing a scene
with
you know maybe an up-and-coming actor
who's getting their moment to shine
right there how can you kind of bring
the best out of them in their role
well as the rain might recall i like to
talk
but i feel like one thing i just really
like to i love being on set and i love
talking to other actors and this
particular group of people was so
extraordinary
that i like to chat everybody up but i
think that um
i hope anyway that that that creates an
experience
uh where people feel that we're all part
of a whole you know i think whatever you
can do
to make sure that where everyone's that
we're all in it together and that you
kind of break down these barriers
and keep communicating keep talking and
i always think if i can bring my energy
my own personal energy to the character
and communicate that to the other actor
then we've built up then we built a bond
um but i don't know lorraine did i talk
too much
well i have something to say about that
um you know what um
he's underplaying what she actually
brought to the set because the bottom
line is
is that julie's generosity set the tone
honest to god and that chatting that she
talks about
is just her extraordinarily
transparent loving giving spirit that
sort of infused
the set because she's she is the glory
she's the star of the film
and so when she opened her arms and
opened the doors and suddenly we were so
embraced by
her um it made it a very safe place to
work it made it a joyous place to work
it was fun
um we it was road
remember more than once julie coming in
to shut us up you guys have to be quiet
now we were very noisy
um but we were having a wonderful time
creating
and the creative time and it was a
heightened creative time and so
enjoy so it was lovely lovely i feel
like you can
feel that pure enjoyment when you're
watching those scenes too so it's
something i really appreciated
um i also wanted to ask you lorraine
just about uh flow in general because
there are a lot of people in addition to
gloria in this movie who really deserve
their own
feature film so if i mean if or when
flo gets her own movie what part of her
life would you be most excited to share
with other people the secret parts of
her life
the the the part of her that was
really genuinely courageous
and and you know how did she overcome
those doubts
because you know this is a woman who who
staged a pee
in of the lawns of harvard where
she had women pee on the lawn i mean
that mind to sort of crawl into the
that the courage of and the imagination
of that
of her activism um was
is kind of a an interesting in electric
place to be
so um the middle of a life probably
you know that's uh that would be a
really interesting place to step into it
and uh julianne one of my favorite
scenes
in the movie was the uh the moment in
the cab and you know gloria's
pretty measured throughout the entire
film and you know that was
kind of i i think it might have been the
only outburst we see from her in the
entire movie so what was it like
preparing for a moment like that and
also
pinpointing why of all the things she
went through that was the moment that
sparked that
well you know it's interesting that you
said that because that was the most
challenging thing for
for me to do because i don't have any
evidence of her in all of her recordings
and anything that i've that i
saw of her exploding of her getting
angry
so we so we don't have never seen it
visually i i haven't heard it
um and and she writes about it she
writes about it in the book she talks
about this
experience she has with his cab driver
and beginning and yelling and getting
out
but i didn't know how to do it you know
so that was the one place where it felt
the most alien to me because i didn't
know
i i hadn't seen the evidence you know so
it was it was a little bit of a leap of
faith
and you kind of had to go with what her
rhythm was in in in her in the book
and and i think it was it was
accomplished it's interesting she talks
about
um what she was hearing on the radio and
how she asked
um the cab driver to to turn down
um the howard's howard stern who was
talking about a school shooting
and and that sort of set her off um so
so you kind of understand like she was
just it was just all too much for her
if i have time to squeeze in one more i
i feel like julianne i have to ask you
this
because i have a jurassic park tattoo
and i can't help it have you ever
i do and i adore it have you ever been
approached to return for one of the
movies and if not
would you ever because i feel like
there's more to that character that i
need to see on screen oh yeah sarah
harding maybe she's not done yet i don't
know but no one has approached me
that's okay but if they did yeah sure of
course
of course isn't it okay thank you for
remembering
i adore that franchise with all my heart
i also adored this film thank you both
so much for your time today i really
appreciate it thank you